in this capsule we will see how
can we specify the structure
a country network
so we have seen previously commented this
that we could estimate the stage of
probability of a Bézian network for a
new problem for which we want
use networked now this
what are we going to see?
can derive the network structure for
a given problem
so a first approach that is
perhaps the simplest in terms of
work to do is to do it at the
hand so we do six does not approach who is
simple to the extent that if one does not have
many variables to model it's
perhaps simpler than having to
collect data
so what do we do the procedure that we
could follow knows we enumerate
all of our xange variables
icaic scene we want to use for
model another environment that one
will choose an order among these variables
so and that could be in our
example of talent and that it could be
if a burglary and kz2 after two
earthquakes and insidious and now of the
first variable until the last
alright i'm going to add the variable to my
network was played in my structure
of data that represents my network I
will add the variable here to my
network
and here I will determine what should
to be my parents from bixi to
from the previous variables of the ex
until eksi - so it's in others
words what should be the parents
such as who are they who made the
conditional probability of maria bixi
and gave all the precedents can get
reduce as the priority of the six
departures only from parents so in
done at this moment if I'm trying to
find out what are the independences
conditional that I can afford to
model then who are likely
for my given problem
so in fact making a choice
which makes that I can start from the simple
rule of chaining in a Bezier network
to arrive at a formulation can more
or the parties concerned
I need it is only those who
depend on the parents I will have chosen
and therefore build a good network Beziers
to the extent that represents
well modelers our environment
our problem is that its structure
reflects conditional independence
that make sense so that is reflected in
my problem I have is to model
and but in fact it's not the only one
important part in the deliberation
of structure it turns out that choosing
the order in which I add but we
are at the bezze network whose order
in which I treat my different
menus can I identify the parents
it is also an important aspect of
my procedure to describe the structure
my network beziers who see an impact
important on the end result is in
do what we want to do is put in
first root causes in the nude
so the first draws in my art of
variables I should put that
I call the causes talks
first in my environment
pim is subsequently those who are
influenced by these root causes so
to illustrate the impact that this can
have two hours of variables that is
maybe not appropriate where I do not have the
root causes first during our
case our example with the soul system
or rather than put burglaries and
who are the features the causes
roots I'm going to put in first husband
call and call by sochaux
I will watch alarm finally
burglaries and earthquake there for the
first random variable I do
just the agitated so m
but barely he adds in that if
I have no choice but to finally do it
no parent since no variables
random
now imagine that I add
laboratory people barely
and here I have to determine what are his
parents is it by a cm or
is what we do for my environment
politics
the distribution of j knowing m can be
reduce as being just a
distribution on j so basically I have to
determine is knowing
that marie called should influence the
distribution on my verbal veracity I
so call intimately I can not
do this reduction there ie
that knowing m is actually worth having a
impact on the distribution of j so
actually if i know that marie has
called upon my prediction sure I
call will not change to know that he
are some good things that I called
if I observe that marie called so
in what if I can not do this
reduction there I can not choose that j
have no parents I have to add as
parent acted the wedding random variable
so I'm going to have an arrow like that
we consider my third variable
random at hand is what he
should have as parents I have m so
the two previous labs where is
what can I reduce his only j or
to have absolutely no independence
when if I can not do it
reduction actually if I observe
firstly that marie called ya
good chances whether it's because
the alarmed was triggered
so I want at least conditioned pops up
now if pardon on marie pie xi in
plus I observe that jean apps additionally
to have served that mary to pleyben that me
strengthens
the prediction that there really was
one to the dance that if I have to have my
two arrows like this here we look
for the 4th random variable
burglary do I have to
conditioned on the three variables to the
previous times where can I
reduce to only the soul or is this
that in fact she is independent of
alarm
I call and marry call when if
it's reasonable to say that I can
condition only on the soul but
why jean and marie actually they
only observe the tear
he also does not observe a burglary or
or not so if I observe that an alarm
marie and jean 1 map is not over
of observation then what they observe
not directly burglaries you
just watch there so do this
reduction there is appropriate
now I can not take away the soul
because actually if I know
that an alarm that has a lot more than
chances he had a burglary that
if there was none at the so I'm going
add only an arrow to the soul
to burglaries and finally my
last random variable s6 so
all the previous values ​​these
burglaries alarm jean pierre marie
call can I reduce it to
only the province only to
love or do I have to
conditioned on the fact that had a
burglary or not when not
conditioning on burglaries it reflects
very badly actually my environment my
application so for example if I know
that an alarm but that in addition I observe
that there were no burglaries but
so it strongly reinforces
my prediction that there was indeed a
earthquake then the opposite
well if I observe that an alarm is that a
burglary
well it's probably not because a
earthquake that
there was an alarm so it's more
likely that they did not have any
earthquake
so observing besides who has
had a burglary
in addition to the fact in addition to observe if
an alarm my post at my door of
information that should influence the
conditional distribution of earthquake
so in this case I'm going to have I
will have a burglary addiction
and earthquake in addition to a dependency of
alarm to earthquake so in fact
determined the conditional independence
it's not intuitive at all
to do if we do not give back our variables
in a way that souls and more
is that if we wanted to try
to infer the name of an expert from
determine what are the probabilities
conditional
in practice we also find that cdh
felt like that by thinking about them
tables to enjoy the step of pro liter
conditional in the non-causal sense
it's also something that is
difficult it's actually it's been a
measure it in medicine or experiments
tendency to find it easier
to prioritize pathologies
to symptoms so in the sense that
know that in this sense diagnosis in this
reverse
and in addition another benefit of good
orderly our random variable at the beginning
in a causal sense therefore causes
roots to the random variables
which are rather effects of the causes
roots is that networks bgc we're going
derive as if they are going to have less of
settings we're going to have fewer arrows
actually we observed earlier that we
did not have a network that had the form
as we saw at the very beginning to know
this form here actually we
had more arrows where we had
an arrow like that then an arrow
like that and that's because here
rather than having burglaries and
earthquake we had instead
we had instead marie calls them
people what is the consequence of everything
is that at the notable end of probability
which contain more parameters so
are going to be bigger so another
advantage of putting the variables in a
the right order
it may be to have disobeyed more
simple with fewer arrows less than
less dependency links between
variables and therefore tables of
smaller probability
now what are we doing his opa
axeans explains that we give a
good network structure beziers ben a
little as we suggested before we could
extract probability tables to
from data one could perhaps
also to do the same thing so
to use an adaptive algorithm for
derive the structure of the network béziers
had an approach that works rather
well
it's about doing local research
inspired or in fact that it corresponds
basically had to say yes when we say
we saw when we talked about
local search in capsules
previous so an algorithm that
could use is to start with
an acyclic graph but random so
among others but variable my
network i'm going to put arts when
minutes randomly making sure
on the other hand that my network beziers and
corresponds a serious which is cyclical to
those of that from my data I
will be derived the probability stage to
from the relative frequencies of which I
pose the tail in that if I have
collected observations
then from the observations I can
estimate table to enjoy as being
relative frequencies to part of the
relative frequencies breakthrough of that we're going
start local search where are we going
generate successor graphs with
arches a little different and for each
serious successor I will stay but
the probabilities step and then I'm going
replace my current graph with my
successor graph if the best according
certain criteria and I'm going to talk about
this criterion there in a few moments
and so as in local search well
I'm going to bury myself like that by the way
from a running graph to a better graf
and doing several operations
until I can not get better
the quality of my arm to run this
algorithm years it's going to take me a
notion of a successor graph and
possible choices of two ways to
generate successor graphs that would be
to add an arc to my current graph or
to delete an arc to my current graph
or to reverse an arc in my guy
running so for example if that was it
my current graph here I can
decide to adjust a bow like that I
could have decided to remove the bow here this
who would give the network bézy here I
may decided to reverse the arc here
that they swallow loeb directions that
now is reversed like that so
for all the possibilities of adding
suppression of inversion game could
generate a successor graph then all
consider them take the one who has the
best criterion who is the best who
best reflects my data has gone to
this graph the luther support is like that
until I can not improve
my graph that would correspond to
biking like bing research
local green green bing to generate the
better structure of my network
beziers so what functions objective
finally use by my search for
then bing an objective function that is
often used corresponds to a
combination of two things
it's the combination of the rag
probability of my data - the
complexity of graffiti
so I'm just going to explain the notation
so that I note x1 t up to xmt with
a little excess though as being the tm
given in my dataset that
I collected so you try the number
of my given then exported jk ex mtc the
values ​​of but random variable and
that up to xn in this umpteenth
give peace m
it may be the number of parameters
in my probability tables which
we move back to encode all of my
conditional priorities and so like
objective function
what I want to do with it I want
maximize my objective function in this
this one so I want a network that
assigns high probability to my
comments
ok so since the log is a
function that is growing
if I had to maximize the sum on all
my loch data of the probabilities of
my observations
it's the same as maximizing
finally the probability of all my
observations standards and give so
looking for a structure that allows me
to assign the highest probability
possible to all my data in my
dataset
but I will pay a price
associated with the complexity of my network
bezers ie the number of
parameters and in fact we notice here
that I also have a penalty that
depends on the log of the number was to give
so among other things the idea here is that
this term there plus I gave more is going to be
important this term here here more I give
more importance but the increase is going
to be less big here to see a
haunted linear increase while
here we see an increase the guy
rhythmic art and therefore as you go
I collected data
this term is going to be less and less
important in relation to this term there so
the more I gave that I can afford
to have a complexity a number of
parameters m which is high but by
against I always paid a price and
so intuitively the tag is what this
algorithm did it is that we
looking for a serious one that explains the
data that is to say that gives them to
priorities but that's compact it's up to
say who has the least parameters
possible and this combination the here in
train run to enjoy the data is
a term of complexity of my network
beziers it's a combination that's
often used in practice then who
works well so I will not go anymore in the
detail for this algorithm I wanted
especially in fact you give a
intuition about commenting what we can
infer the structure of a Bezier network
with 1
local search gray this is another
beautiful application of the paces of
local search but in the context
Bezier networks and to find out
I invite you to read section 20
2.5 points of the water milk on the
Nordic